die fahrt nach bockhoff bei moskau
dauert zwei stunden
zwei stunden autofahrt gen osten rumpeln
rutschen über schlechte straßen in eine
andere welt
bockhoff das sind 17.000 einwohner eine
schokoladenfabrik und die allgemeine
strafkolonie nummer zwei hier wohl soll
alexej nawalny bald einsetzen
vielleicht in zwei wochen momentan
befindet er sich in der nähe in
quarantäne
so genau weiß das niemand und vielen
hier ist es auch egal
nein weiß nicht ich mich interessiert
nach wollen ihn nicht ich bin gegen
seine politik und alles was er verzapft
hat es ist gut dass man ihn eingeloggt
hat er macht alles kaputt
er hat die ganze innenpolitik kaputt
gemacht er bringt die jugend vom rechten
weg ab stellt das straflager in bottrop
hat platz für rund 800 häftlinge
eröffnet wurde es 1994 es gibt eine
berufsschule eine kirche und ein gebäude
für treffen mit angehörigen wenig gewalt
viel disziplin so der ruf der anstalt es
heißt aber auch hier machen sie dich
psychisch kaputt
wir treffen vor dem straflager jemanden
der genau weiß wie es innen aussieht
die zeit die ich hier verbracht habe das
waren sehr schwere monate monate eines
ständigen drucks ich durfte nicht
sprechen
man zwang mich völlig sinnlose dinge zu
tun beispielsweise musste ich täglich
mehrere stunden bei frost und hitze zum
appell antreten
konstantin potthoff saß rund ein jahr in
der allgemeinen strafkolonie nummer zwei
weil er mehrfach an illegalen demos
teilnahm
er sagt das leben da drin sei hart
besonders für die psyche sie versuchen
den willen der leute zu brechen
nach außen hin sollen sie zeigen dass
alles in ordnung ist das alles
vorbildlich ist wenn zum beispiel das
stadtfernsehen da ist stehen sie alle in
reih und glied und alle sagen dass alles
ausgezeichnet ist
alexej nawalny wird rund zweieinhalb
jahre im straflager sitzen
ob sie ihn brechen wird die zeit zeigen
der staat jedenfalls räumt ihn aus dem
weg den mann der den staat und seine
vertreter mit seinen internet- videos
seit jahren offen herausfordert zuletzt
sogar den präsidenten persönlich ich
möchte verstehen wie aus einem normalen
sowjetoffizier ein verrückter wurde der
besessen ist von geld das palast video
des navalny teams war ein frontalangriff
einer von dem es kein zurück gibt für
navalny nicht für seine anhänger nicht
und wenig überraschend offenbar auch
nicht für den staatschef
navalny zu isolieren
das war eine entscheidung von ganz oben
sowohl das gericht als auch die
untersuchungsausschüsse und andere
staatsorgane haben sich dieser
entscheidung unterworfen
die kredite von oben werden befolgt das
prinzip ist die vertikale der macht
die gangart wird härter gegenüber allen
die nach wandel rufen sowie arena panis
getan hat heute steht sie an ihrem wie
sie ihn nennt alter erinnert sie an die
schlimmste zeit ihres bisherigen lebens
das ist im prinzip ein kleines museum
zur geschichte meiner zeit in der
haftanstalt sacharow da gibt es zum
beispiel unser tagebuch aus zellen
nummer 4 3 6 10 tage waren es in celle
nummer 4 36 ihre erlebnisse ihre ängste
hat sie festgehalten auf dünnem papier
arena war mit ihrem verlobten zum
gericht gekommen vor dem navalny
haftstrafe verhandelt worden war
babbel und ich waren auf dem
fußgängerweg unterwegs ohne jemanden zu
stören schweigend ohne slogans
da kam ein offizier auf uns zu warum
weiß ich nicht er hatte keine
erkennungszeichen er brachte uns zum
gefangenen
transporter pavel landet in celle 150
von dort schreibt er seiner verlobten
regelmäßig versucht den kontakt zu
halten aufwühlende zeiten für beide
sie haben an diesem tag viele
intellektuelle verhaftet eine meiner
zellengenossinnen war eine doktorandin
eine griechisch lehrerin
es gab künstler programmierer unter den
häftlingen drei computerprogrammierer
der staat macht ernst im dumawahl ja wer
zur falschen zeit am falschen ort ist
vor allem wer nähe zu navalny zeigt lebt
gefährlich das alles sagen beobachter
aber einen grund navalny ist in der
öffentlichen wahrnehmung zum anführer
der russischen opposition geworden
er tritt als eine alternative zu putin
auf natürlich betrifft dass putin
persönlich
ich glaube allerdings nicht dass putin
den ganzen tag darüber nachdenkt was
mittlerweile nie zu tun ist er sagt
bitte klären sie das mittlerweile andere
kümmert sich dann darum
marina pan und ihr verlobter pabel
versuchen die haftzeit zu verarbeiten so
wie viele andere werden sie so bald
nicht wieder in die nähe einer demo
gegen das system der abschreckung wirkt
auch bei den jungen leuten die navalny
mehr zugetan sind als die älteren
der schock über ihre haftstrafe
jedenfalls sitzt ihnen noch in den
knochen
diese schokolade hat mir mein nachbar im
gefangenen transporter gegeben
wir nannten sie scherzhaft die medaille
für mut all dieses erinnert mich an das
was ich ertragen musste marina pan
möchte keine zweite haftstrafe und
sicher auch keine zweite medaille für
ihren mut